ross when you decided you wanted to
become a television writer
before you got into teaching um how
important was it to you that you
achieved that goal i mean that was that
your mindset from the beginning once you
left berkeley that you were going to
well it's funny i when i was at berkeley
i did some comedy writing in school
uh i actually had a sketch radio comedy
program
along with a childhood friend joel cerna
who turned out to be one of the creators
of 24 eventually
and we did sketch comedy on the radio
which is about as difficult as you can
imagine because
in comedy you need to hear if the
audience is laughing or not and you
don't on the radio
so it would be you'd do something you
thought was funny and
maybe the engineer would laugh but you
would just hope somebody was listening
out there
and i also wrote for the humor magazine
at berkeley which is where i went to
college
but simultaneous all this i got a summer
job through my father working for a
company that made
television commercials my father was an
advertising executive and so
i got a job as a gopher a pa for company
made
mcdonald's and united airlines and
kentucky fried chicken commercials
and i loved it it was hugely fun it
didn't matter how demeaning the work
was one of my first jobs this is a true
story
i was a i stood in for a dog in a dog
food commercial
on my hands and knees face near the bowl
and so on
because i was cheaper to hire me than to
hire a second dog
because if they hire they don't want to
tire out the star dog and if you hire a
second dog you have to have a second
union animal handler
and so i was cheaper than that i think
there was some good natured hazing going
on as well because
my father was an advertising executive
and i was probably the 9 000th
son of an advertising executive who got
a summer job but i had a great time
so by the time i graduated from college
i was torn about whether to
go pursue writing or pursue production
and
frankly i wasn't good enough to be a
professional writer at that time
so it was the better path for me to
pursue production
and practice writing write spec scripts
and get better at them
and it hadn't even quite gotten on my
radar to be a sitcom writer yet
that happened when i moved back to los
angeles and just in
socializing found out that the older
brothers and sisters of my friends were
some of them were getting jobs as sitcom
writers
and i thought hey i'd like to do that so
my
my school for that was they showed
reruns of the mary tyler moore show and
the bob newhart show where he was the
psychologist in the afternoon so when i
was unemployed
i had freelance employment as a
commercial production assistant at that
time when i was unemployed i'd watch the
shows in the afternoon
and i'd try to scrape up scripts from
somewhere to read them it's much easier
now
to learn your to at least get the
resources to learn your craft
we they didn't even have vhs tape
machines at that time when i was
starting out so
all you could do was watch tv to study
something now go
watch 50 episodes of something on dvd or
stream it or whatever
and the scripts are available on the
internet